ghana's president and chairman of equals
nana coforado calls it a contagion
the rest of africa and the continent's
western ally is watched with concern
after multiple military calls in west
africa the resurgence of coup d'etats in
our region is a matter of grave concern
this evolution
challenges the democratic way of life we
have chosen
let us address this danger this
dangerous trend collectively and
decisively
before it devastates the whole region
the threats of sanctions cutting of
economic ties and shutting borders have
so far failed to dissuade cool plotters
in the region in less than two years at
least four cores have taken place in
west africa including two in mali
with no success in regional leaders
effort to get mali back to democratic
system there are fears that potential
coup plotters in west africa could be
emboldened that experts say was what
happened in guinea-bissau aku was
recently foiled they warned that failure
to send a stronger signal including
military intervention makes the regional
bloc look weaker and irrelevant in the
light of recent political developments
in the region
the only military commitment the leaders
can give for now is on guinea bissau
only for stabilization purposes
in the short term
to prevent any situation requires have
decided to to send a
false day that will help in the
stabilization
process of stabilization again of the
country
experts say with the spate of military
crews in the region even the most stable
democracies are now vulnerable a lot of
these so-called democratically elected
you know
countries okay they claim to be
democratically elected engaged in
selling activities that looks more like
military dictatorship they manipulate
constitutions so they can extend their
rule there's gross violation of rights
they are not able to deliver on the two
main functions of the state including
one human security and secondly fiscal
security the last time west african
leader sent the military force to stop
unconstitutional change of government
was five years ago
that diplomat forced into exile former
gambian president yaya jamie who refused
to concede defeat after losing an
election
but at the moment member states are not
keen to send their soldiers to confront
cool leaders on their own term
many are having to fight their own
battles against internal and external
threats but if and when they agree to
other factors will come into play
these include where funds for such a
force will come from
what will be its mandate and for how
long
questions that leaders at this summit
have no answers for at least for now
mohammed
al jazeera accra ghana